a death can come at any time
and you don't have to be very active,
very aware, very vigilant, because living
in a country where there is a conflict, that's
how you live
with fear all the time, it
's logical
that no one if we mean
November 24,  2016 is signed
in Havana Cuba- the peace agreement between
the national government and the FARC for the
end of the conflict and the
construction of a stable and
lasting peace more or less 75 percent of
the demobilized of the country that are
about 59  thousand demobilized in the
last 16 15 years
were victims before being victimizers
were recruited as minors
or were involved in the
conflict for serious violations against
their person
my name is natalia
ribera taborda I am 20 years old I joined
the  FARC
bombed us at the company where I
belonged,
this was like at 12 o'clock at night,
so I remember a lot because my
cove was, let's say, here and at Ladit  or there lived
a girl who loved her very much,
unfortunately she, well, in
today's bor band that maybe she caught her sleeping she
didn't get to vote for the trench and she
died
there are versions you are and when they kind of
look at him shattered saying help me don't leave me
if you  times yes remember that writing
[Music]
his vision in the bees process
schuchat his fracture rehabilitate people
that had been symbol of invaded the
cert report and forty years eve and want to
be live jane de aggressive and javier adán
large level we need to complete change
of intervention' process you can provide
house a work
social security for ex-combatientes but
the hub trauma left forty years of
experience expulsen to violence or not
only in Colombia ba dinh the rest of the
world monster real and tayson programs and
not evidence-based win it  to get
founding from the government to provide
a ekström and systematic rehabilitation-
processes regalen to social with mission
and social adaptation of casualties more
i  important or there's dimension of
rehabilitation' process 93% of the
people who enter the
reintegration process come with
psychosocial disorders, some more serious than others
and others definitely very serious that
would already go from psychosocial to
psychological and some of these
psychiatric ones we have  post-
traumatic stress we
have anxiety disorders we have attention deficit
we have a number of diseases that
if they are not taken into account for the
reintegration process the
demobilized person will not advance on his route
my name is wilson young
Galician gentleman I lasted 15 years in the farc I joined
at
the age of 16
something hard that I had to do and that
bothers me and what and what I do
n't want because
as he is lying down remembering very
constantly it
is the execution people
talking about people that I want from
ordinary civilians who worked for the
enemy
share this with you
because, well,
because I want the people
who  Listen to the people
who see me, what they
feel, let them know that this was
not, it was not my own decision, it was not for my
liking, it was not because I am like this,
and above all, they can forgive us, it
was not of their own free will, because it was
a hobby or  why because we like to
do that but because
the lives of all of us are also in danger
in his series we believe that the colombian
conflict that only opportunity until the
living lab understand of real life
interwin between biology psychology and
cultural factor involved in violence and
criminal bigger
quest argued empatitis because we touch
a the beginning of the combats will
have a lula
in a draw however we found age is
natural basic life and death
ex-combatants hub the world feels
empathy for the Colombian regular power
about their empathy too twitter bicol
not all of the  heart problem no tie
microsoft research we found the weekend
offer its escalation to the commission
training de 36 recognition emotion  nal
recognition theory of mine recognize and social
killed the night coaching in the
same situation institution stop your
aggressive activity and javier attend we
can intervention implement into a
mental health approach
I say this
personally 100% I have changed 99
percent well for me  It seems to me that the most
difficult thing about being an ex-combatant and
outsiders, that is, is that many
many look at us as weirdos,
like there are terrorists, like things like that, there is a
sign of society at large is not ready
to versions people and we need
society  rehabilitation process that is
more challenging and providing individual
rehabilitation to
each of the people who are in the
armed conflict for whatever reason
we are human beings we can change
we can be someone in life we can contr
bute to society we can move the c
untry forwa
d together we can  make a country of
Colombia a much better country
[Music]